[Applaudissements]
salle chauffée à blanc jamais les
électeurs de pedro ne se sont autant
passionné pour une élection européenne
eux qui ont voté à 60 % 2016 pour
quitter l'union tous ici mais james est
furieux que son vote pour le break site
n'est toujours pas été exaucé biden
ces élections ne devrait même pas avoir
lieu on aurait dû déjà avoir quitté
l'europe depuis longtemps dit il mais on
s'est fait avoir par nos députés au
parlement
weprin un sentiment largement partagé
ici oui à moubarak c'est la frustration
dont espère bien tirer parti nadjaf
des pans entiers de l'autre
establishment essaie de nous enlever le
drake s'est dit ils sont partis le parti
spécialement pour l'occasion n'a qu'un
seul but s'assurer de quitter l'euro une
situation paradoxale car nigel farrage
fait campagne pour être élus au
parlement de bruxelles
sa stratégie est claire exploiter
l'impopularité de la première ministre
britannique theresa may qui n'a pas
réussi à faire adopter leurs excès elle
nous a humiliés
elle a fait de nous la risée du monde
entier dixon si nous sommes nombreux à
voter pour le président pâtit elle va
devoir partir la recette est visiblement
en payant le prix excède parties mènent
actuellement largement dans les sondages
avec plus du tiers des intentions de
vote
dans ce pub de londres une autre
ambiance un autre contexte politique car
la capitale britannique a voté en 2016 à
60% contre le break si farouchement pro
europe beaucoup de londoniens n'ont
toujours pas digéré le résultat du
référendum
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a poussé jasick
assez mal à se lancer en politique
ça fait trois ans que je me bats contre
l'hôte brixi dit elle et cette élection
c'est un peu deuxième référendum sur la
question
jessica va défendre les couleurs de
chengdu qu'est un nouveau parti né il y
à peine quelques semaines un parti créé
spécialement pour lutter contre le
brésil c'est la seule question
actuellement dit elle car si on n'arrête
pas le principe ça va monopoliser la
politique pour les dix prochaines années
militant de gauche james dyson s'est
porté volontaire pour aider la campagne
de changzhou qu'est frustré par la
position ambiguë de travailler sur des
sites avec le break site a détruit notre
réputation dit il tout le monde rit de
nous maintenant nous sommes vus comme
des idiots
fondée par une poignée de députés
dirt en travaillistes comme
conservateurs chengdu qui fait campagne
au centre et espère rallier des
opposants breakes site déçus des partis
traditionnels comme greg gerry qui
promet de ne plus jamais voter
conservateur veulent que ce soit pour ou
contre le président
les britanniques se rejoignent sur un
point leur rejet des politiciens et des
partis traditionnels conservateurs et
travaillistes qui dominent le jeu
politique ici depuis toujours ne
réunisse pour cette élection selon un
récent sondage qu'un tiers des
intentions de vote
sept analystes n'hésitent pas à parler
d'une crise politique sans précédent
on sent un phénomène de ras-le-bol 1
notamment vis-à-vis de négociation de ce
que constitue le break site mais aussi
la classe politique en général
ras-le-bol qui aura permis l'émergence
de discours de plus en plus populiste
personnifié d'abord et avant tout par
nigel fera campagne pour leur réussite
en 2016 avait largement fait appel aux
sentiments anti immigration
c'est quelqu'un qui effectivement dans
un registre populiste de droite bas
droite extrême
ne laisse personne indifférent de toute
évidence qu'il se concrétise ou non le
brix et aura un impact à long terme sur
la vie politique au royaume uni sur la
relation des britanniques avec leurs
élus et le regard qu'ils portent sur les
est sûre leur pays un pays qui se
retrouvent aujourd'hui plus polarisé que
jamais ici jean françois bélanger
radio-canada plomb